pour les amis là c'est très sérieux
c'est très très grave ce qu'on vit la
guerre est relancée en a parlé hier ça
faisait quelques temps déjà que madame
de fontenay avait lâché nathalie marquay
mais lundi elle s'est bien rattrapé
aller jingle tout de suite
c'est le quart d'heure sans filtre sur
le plateau de nantes soit people je lui
avais été très dure voire méchantes
envers son ancien ennemi alors à ses
yeux c'est bien simple nathalie n'aurait
jamais dû devenir miss france on a le
plaisir d'accueillir tout de suite
nathalie marquay pernaut
j'étais avec les ibères guérin qu'on
applaudit également
et alors avant avant de commencer à
débattre les amis parce que vous avez
sûrement des choses à vous dire je vous
sens un peu tendu tous les deux hommes
pas du tout quoi bon on dit là on va
voir la déclaration de la jeune veuve
qui a mis le feu aux poudres
nathalie marquay pernaut j'ai jamais
compris ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est ce
qu'il est passé par la tête là quand on
a commencé à parler de couilles tout ça
de trucs vulgaire ça vous à l'opinion
publique que voulait la réunionnaise et
miss réunion il s'en sortait pas des
bulletins et tout ça c'est fini ben par
l'alsace ça veut dire quoi c'est un vote
truqué bassine de se dire que c'était
son titre oui il était si c'était si
miss alsace est devenue miss roi henri
vous avez trouvé ça bizarre ben oui bien
sûr en gros ce que vous me dites
geneviève de fontenay c'est lors de
l'élection de nathalie marquay-pernaut
ça devait être une autre miss et ça a
été l pour un fait du hasard qu'on
connaît ben oui c'est pour ça qu'il ya
quand même d'accord pas dévoile un
thalys extrêmement violent quand même
non oui et en même temps pas très très
grave entre noah maintenant ça fait 35
ans vous rendez compte j'étais jeune là
maintenant et ça y est justement spider
man 796 donc ça va faire 30
87.7 alsace 86-87 l'élection miss france
et 87 exactement donc
c'est vraiment surprenant qu'elle dise
ça parce que
et pourtant vous étiez en bons termes
oui un traître elle avait dit des choses
présentées sur vous je me souviens
j'étais son rayon de soleil pendant au
moins 15 ans c'est depuis 2005 où il ya
eu l'histoire avec du cru et pour la
ferme célébrités où j'ai été harcelée
par les journalistes
et pendant trois mois j'ai donné une
nouvelle à personne et elle s'est vexé
et donc comme elle est amie avec les
journalistes france dimanche et tout ça
elle a voulu
parler pour pour exister et là elle a
dit elle un pois chiche dans la tête et
s est à part se faire culbuter dans les
bottes de foin c'est tout ce qu'elle
fait à la cam célébrités donc là quand
même excusez moi on peut dire son grand
âge et tout ça mon lahya c'est en 2005
donc j'ai un peu moins âgés quand même
et là mais c'est choquant pour ma
famille pour mes enfants pour moi même
pas ce mois qu'il aimait tant parce que
je l'aimé énormément man fin ça a été
une deuxième mère pour moi et là je n'ai
rien compris alors hubert hubert vous
êtes collaborateurs hubert guérin
collaborateurs de geneviève de fontenay
mais sa liste en concours miss france en
plus oui qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qui s'est passé pourquoi même en
arriver là non mais je voudrais
simplement ré expliquer des choses
peut-être plus clairement et notamment à
nathalie qui a été clair non en fait
s'il faut bien ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est quand des 186 et la
première élection miss france qu'ils
avaient été télévisées geneviève de
fontenay dans la vidéo que vous venez
montrer ne dis pas que l'élection miss
france est truqué les journalistes ont
interprété comme un trucage de
l'élection qu'est ce qui s'est passé
l'élection se déroulait aux buttes
chaumont elle était présentée par guy
lux et empereur des jeux télé qui fait
un affrontement entre régions et
l'alsace est une région on va dire à
nice où on se mobilise fortement et ses
107 votes élections à 42 hockey qui est
incontestable a montré le meilleur
simplement bernard les six mois terminés
simplement lorsqu'il s'est produit c'est
quelle langue à l'école dans le public y
avait il une préférence entre guillemets
le public préféré miss réunion je
préférais miss réunion voilà même si
d'accord avec et en fait c'était europe
qui à l'époque gérer les votes c'était
pas le mastodonte médiatique qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui c'était pas le
phénomène de société on l'a vu non mais
attendez tout ça c'est important
contexte et les journalistes d'europe 1
on mélange est
d'accord mais c'est ça l'histoire les
leads nathalie marquay pernaut a alors
les
des trucs avec l'élection de nathalie
marquay pernaut n'a pas était la voix
dégonfler la
ramener son papier remercie gilles
aurait donné les preuves on aurait
continué là dessus je sais
madame de fontenay n'a pas dit dans
l'extrait convient de montrer que
l'intérêt des titres ici
elle a dit que les disques durs sont
allées on leur met vous allez voir le
temps régime services élargie tpm paie
d'impôts par année alors qu'un père nous
j'ai jamais compris ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'il y est passé par la
tête quand on a commencé à parler de
couilles tous à des trucs vulgaire ça
vous à l'opinion publique que voulait la
réunionnaise et miss réunion il s'en
sortait pas des bulletins et tout ça
c'est fini ben par l'alsace ça veut dire
quoi c'est un vote truqué bah c'est à
dire que c'était son titre wii n'était
si c'était si miss alsace est devenue
miss france vous avez trouvé ça bizarre
ben oui bien sûr lorsque vous me dites
geneviève de fontenay c'est lors de
l'élection de nathalie marquay-pernaut
ça devait être une autre miss et ça a
été l pour un fait du hasard qu'on
connaît ben oui c'est pour ça que la
chance quand même d'accord non mais
attends ta vie attendait j&j l'enquêté
nous a sorti les chiffres y hier ouais
après on les voyait d'ailleurs ces fêtes
qui s'est passé c'est que geneviève de
fontenay a dit moi j'aime beaucoup mais
l'a dit n'importe quoi et là vous êtes
en tant que représentant madame de
fontenay on est d'accord oui d'accord
donc vous êtes en train de préparer un
livre
qui se veut trash et l'art moderne au
monde rock là vous êtes en porte à faux
parce que l a dit une grosse bêtise et
vous tenté de rectifier mais elle a dit
que l'élection ait été truquée et cette
élection n'était pas truqué et monsieur
que l'on y est normal que je le connais
parce que je connais ce monsieur à bord
monsieur alors maintenant bon ben
voilà on est en train de le faire pas de
souci ça la rassure monsieur a réussi à
s'immiscer dans l'entourage de geneviève
de fontenay nathalie le sait très bien
mais à tomber monsieur
vous répondrais c'est un but extrêmement
sulfureux et là il se dit ouah mon livre
va être décrédibiliser si ça commence
comme ça donc je tente de venir jouer
les pompiers et calmer le jeu donc là
vous êtes en représentant de geneviève
de fontenay très emmerder pas ce que
vous dites si ça part comme sa chaîne à
[Rires]
vivre trash ou bien les photos cette
fille a collaboré ou alors cela va
réparer des princes alors
donnez
moi j'ai dit non vous m'avez t l'atelier
meja vous est proposé c'est parce les
noms n'ont malheureusement
c'est pas un livre définitivement il ya
plusieurs miss france qui ont donné des
interviews et j'ai passé un très bon
moment pendant l'interview les questions
étaient vraiment pertinente et tout et
c'était super donc c'est no comment dire
chaque miss france comment elle a vécu
son année et à celle
de miss
france qui
est en fait moi j'ai fait le livre en
donnant un peu les interviews fin plus
ou moins pour le livre de sylvie là je
me suis dit que c'était normal aussi de
le faire pour genève fontenay même si je
ne les ai jamais rencontrés mais
nathalie elle a quand même parlé sans
doute que je n'ai fontenay a vu ce
passage aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle pense c'est quoi sa thèse
en fait qu'est ce qu'elle pense
geneviève de fontenay elle extrêmement
ennuyé de ce qui est en train de se
produire voilà simplement
nation elle n'a pas dit dans l'interview
que l'élection de nathalie
marquay-pernaut elle insinue sans
permission dans
la tête de les gens c'est truqué des
quais matin oui monsieur vous n'êtes pas
vous n'êtes pas les gens et vous n'êtes
pas la presse
tous les journalistes m'appellent alors
est ce que votre élection est truqué on
va arrêter de me harceler au téléphone
pour avoir je ne suis pas responsable du
fait que
ma navigation mais n'ont jamais d'accord
mais enfin je suis là sur le plateau
madame
c'est justement que l'on attend dé beir
vos quatre collaborateurs de madame de
fontenay est ce que vous pensez que ça a
été truquée ou pas
nathalie marquay-pernaut miss france
1987 diffusé le 31 décembre 1986 mis sur
fr3 mais n'a pas été truqué voilà
pourquoi geneviève vie ça sentait laisse
entendre cela tout simplement parce que
c'était il ya 35 ans 37 ans et
aujourd'hui je rappelle pas elle a
aujourd'hui quatre ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais sinon je la mettrais parce que si
vous travaillez geneviève qu'on aime
beaucoup et qu'on va se fait au bout
d'un avocat me piquer adonne bien que
maintenant il faut arrêter fainéants
thématiquement dominant en prendre un
arrêté laissez moi parler deux secondes
séparent les bocaux soit la civic ailier
choix soit la tan y avait assez sage
systématiquement quand on se rapproche
des dictons pour faire parler d'elle
elle a fait un travail formidable à
l'académie de france ce qu'elles sont
devenues maintenant franchement elle a
vu le jour et que d'abord il faudrait un
qu'elle se rappelle des choses quand
précisément 10 mai où il ya des trous de
mémoire dans son chapeau et
au bout de la maman excusez moi aller
entre adam minutes mais ce qu'elle a
fait de bien dans sa vie on est en train
de la prendre en grippe on ne la
supporte plus la zone diem je vous dis
franchement elle nous agace ça nous
énerve tirs au but les locaux piste est
large et le monsieur vous géré la
communication madame de fontenay et vous
venez de la défoncer sur le plateau
[Applaudissements]
très bien moi je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire vous dire la vérité
aujourd'hui à très très proches de
madame de fontenay m'a dit c'est pour ça
que j'étais énervé ému parce que je
l'aimais beaucoup j'aime bien de
fontenay vous étiez un parasite
[Applaudissements]
et que vous aviez profité de la
faiblesse des ventes et ont essayé de
rassembler ses souvenirs me faire à
l'idée
de repenser à ce livre
attendez juste un truc elle-même
nathalie a dit hier en fin de juillet
elle a dit que son entourage qu'elle
serait mauvais aussi acquis que c'est
l'entourage de madame de fontenay était
très mauvais toxiques en tout cas oui
alors vous pensiez à qui vous pensiez à
12h non quelqu'un d'autre que je
pourrais pas dire ah non non on a tenu à
ne pas les sept pages et la tania moi tu
vas me le dire gg je peux pas je ne peux
vraiment pas dire désolé nous maintenons
du jour nathalie nathalie il faut dire
non il faut dire que non mais il faut
dire on est très très proches il faut il
faut dire à quai pour cent c'est parce
que là on fils peut-être à son fils
alors voilà déjà que rentrer la norme
cela fait encore d'autres histoires on
va rentrer encore dit oui mais là c'est
pire mais demander des choses
je ne suis pas un parasite dans
l'entourage de madame de fontenay je
travaille avec elle depuis dix ans le
livre elle a donné son accord en étant
pleinement consciente de ce qu'elle
était en train de faire c'est un livre
que je mène avec son accord elle en
signe la préface il sortira dans
quelques mois les miss france elle a
évidemment son mot à dire sur les miss
france y collaborent à l' ouvrage et
lorsque nous avons évoqué le cas de
nathalie marquay-pernaut je vous cache
pas qu'elle n'a pas sauté de joie à
l'idée qu'elle collabore au livre mais
en tout cas elle m'a pas dit non à
l'appel surtout pas voilà donc elle est
aussi soucieuse du fait qu' elle veut
que le livre rend compte de ce qu'elle a
fait durant saviez vous me disiez que
vous en avez marre de l'entendre etc
mais miss france et c'est toute sa vie
alors à laval a vendu à l'abandon à la
vendeuse ya des raisons j'ai plus de
propriétés c'est à l'avant deux ans déjà
je ne peux cacher des choses positives
blessé sur la vente c'est pas parce
qu'un oeil mark hominick mieux
s'exprimer sur miss france qu'elle va
arrêter moi quand je vois une bagnole
après-demain kyriba ils demandent pas
les clés étaient venus elle n'a pas les
clefs miss france aujourd'hui oui mais
voilà elle avait osé y avait la misére
n'est rien de plus que miss quand miss
camping plus la télé jack bauer c'est
pas parce que c'est une réalité les
populaires à l'honneur avec madame
naissante mais je pense pas que madame
de fontenay pense à ça oui madame a
pris envers tous les gens qui
travaillent pour les messieurs chaque
année et tous les gens qui regardent les
mascottes au but mais
c'était la même temps
[Applaudissements]
absolument je suis prêt à m'expliquer
les masques ne devront pas du tout sur
la question de musique en ligne sur la
commune et que c'est pour expliquer que
c'est un divertissement qui est à la
base populaire est fondée sur les
régions et qui devient un mastodonte
médiatique effectivement ils voudraient
par rapport aux équipes de tête c'est un
métier mais l'art équipe de tf1
participe au livre nommé d'accord mais
ça je suis pas en train de remettre en
question j'ai juste que la phrase que
vous avez tenus c'est des propos qui
sont quand même pas très très très
sympathique envers tous les gens
travaillent pour cet hiver
de santé qui comme vous dites a donné sa
vie pour cette émission je vous préviens
tout de suite moi je pense que c'est
miss camping qu'on les appelait
n'engagent que je rédige je vais mettre
mon avis sur un concours de beauté
rupture fait que vous avez que vous avez
vues dans des songes la mort de john
berry et jean-paul belmondo j'ai parlé
du refus ouvrage à sa dalle fait une
nation des cousettes miss camping ça
vous fait plaisir à me lancer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
y'a vous dire mes enfants du rêve c'est
à plusieurs missions avant d'être élue
miss france ont été élues miss
qu'emploie
aussi une déconnade on avait du champion
du champignon du champagne à gagner du
foie gras
des journaux excusez moi il ya un truc
que je comprends pas en fait vous
représentez la communication du comité
miss france lance un communiste comme
quoi on fait mais il avoue défense et en
fait
non
c'est parler au nom des
contrats de dénigrer
vulgaire comme vulgaire
mais là votre com a éclaté et les
dénigrements de bahia justin de
betteraves moi c'est comme ça que je
prends
dans une guerre concours si j'estimais
que miss france et 1,1 avant que je
tremblais bovine façon lui parler et une
communication qui est zéro je vous dis
tout de suite franchement vous donnez
nous
chanter tout ce qu'elle a fait 15 0 non
mais ça file en tout cas les courants
faut lui faire un procès d'intention et
la manière dont vous m'avez fait
l'interview je vois que vous êtes un
passionné de miss vous connaissez tous
et toutes
miss camping ça veut peut-être dire sans
doute un peu plus limitée sur le terroir
et tout parce qu'on est toutes des
filles de terroir avant d'être mais dès
qu'il est tout à fait et vous m'avez
expliquer votre histoire quand vous
prenez le train pour la première fois
pour aller lui
donc c'est ça aussi le concours miss
france et lorsque nathalie marquay
pernaut s'est présenté sur france 3
c'était simplement un concours des
régions mis à la télévision 1195
l'émission est passé sur terrain où là
on a eu affaire à la mise en place d'un
alors phénomène de société au mas
industrialisés miss france on en a fait
une cérémonie télévisuelle devant lequel
les français semblent être surpris cette
dizaine d'années pardon mais est-ce que
geneviève de fontenay est obligé avec
tout le respect que du doigt parce que
je pense qu'à l'avenir comme vous dites
il a donné sa vie est ce qu'elle est
obligée aujourd'hui de revenir que sur
des moments qui sont négatifs et de
taper sur quelqu'un
non cinq ans il ya une prescription dans
nos amis les femmes appelées j'ai appelé
geneviève de fontenay geneviève
geneviève tu m'entends
bon est-ce que tu regarde la télé en ce
moment elle est en direct et on parle de
évidemment il ya nathalie marqué avec
nous pernaut et il ya monsieur hubert
guérin qui travaille avec toi qu'est ce
que tu as envie de dire en direct en
tout cas c'est gentil que tu décroches
qu'on entend
alors il ya eu triche pas triche comme
tu l'as laissé entendre geneviève
est ce qu'il ya eu triche aux pattes
riches comme tu l'as laissé entendre une
bonne maîtrise technique
très calme truqués ou pas truqué cette
élection la première élection avec nate
heures
voilà merci
la première
en direct et c'est
avec avec nos écharpes en d'entendre le
résultat et le résultat est passé entre
qui lui est
miss réunion
oui c'est ce qu'on a vu dis-moi
geneviève pas pardon ma geneviève mais
tant collaborateurs a parlé de miss
camping est ce que ça te choque en
parlant de miss en son nom n'a encore
pas si la douce
tration
mais alors malheur elles viennent et
geneviève dans l'émission là on a
diffusé les images les enfants s'il vous
plaît c'est difficile déjà téléphone
s'il vous plaît
vraiment on a diffusé les images en
tulle s entendre sur notre stand people
que c'était bizarre l'élection de la
thalie qu'est ce que tu as envie de lui
dire elle est sur le plateau avec nous
en direct et elle était très très de
cette histoire
nathalie était très triste de ton
histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la formule rencontre qu'elles étaient
jetés et en 2005 18 ans après son
élection je fais un livre avec sylvie
tellier ou se dit qu'elle a été mais on
rayon de soleil et ensuite de 2005 à
2010 8 je prends contact avec elle pour
tout pour souhaiter un que les
opérations de son mari je place que nous
bien comme directeur quand ça s'est
passé pour après ce coup ils m'ont
réponse j'ai donné quand exemple chez
moi les données exactement j'ai transmis
ce qu'elles sont en porter sur le fait
qu'ils venaient pour être venu pour pour
que vous le donnez vous que vous
montriez que vous le montrions
justement geneviève geneviève tu
m'entends geneviève tu sais que l'on
t'aime beaucoup tous ici on est tous
désolés de cette histoire tu tu
m'entends on est tous désolés cette
histoire nathalie est là et on est
tristes franchement il est combatif mais
triste elle dit mais qu'est ce que tu
aurais envie de lui dire l'aller pas
triste donc n'est pas triste un temps
fou jambes le centre
est a maltraités non madame en effet en
2005 malheureusement notre amitié s'est
arrêté là et vous savez pourquoi
malheureusement parce que vous était
donné le jeune marié a eu avec elle a
dit vous n'êtes pas venu mais aussi je
pense
geneviève je peux te passe et nathalie
[Rires]
cabine téléphonique
formidable attend jeanne bien levé à
temps j'aime bien pardon de te couper je
te passe nathalie mais parce qu'on vous
aime toutes les deux et ça nous fait de
la peine si on t'aime non on attend
maintenant non non non non non non je
suis là madame de segré très contente de
vous entendre de nouveau téléphone ce
sera mieux que que vous en voyez
quelqu'un d'autre à votre place donc
vous savez que pour moi vous avez été
une deuxième mère d'ailleurs j'ai mon
livre qui sort aujourd'hui et j'ai tout
achat chapitre sur vous je dit que du
bien malheureusement depuis 2005 c'est
vous qui avez commencé en me disant que
je me faisais culbuter dans les potes de
paille quand j'étais à l'émission
on parler de madame de fontenay
c'est vous-même défendre et qui m'a
parlé comme ça j'ai été trop oui il ya
très longtemps c'est en 2005 pour la
ferme célébrités tous les journalistes
mais inventer une histoire avec ducruet
et que jean pierre pernaut était le roi
du cocu vous m'avez soutenu j'ai eu
pendant trois mois à la presse où on m'a
ont m'a complètement fracassé et comme
j'ai pu je n'avais pas parlé avec vous
et vous étiez pas contente parce que je
parlais pas avec vous pendant trois mois
et vous avez sorti ça la presse
jean-pierre il en est témoin vous avez
pas dire que mon mari jean pierre
pernaut est un menteur aussi vous avez
peut-être oublié mais cette phrase m'a
fait super mal et comment voulez vous
comment voulez vous après à ce moment là
que moi je ne parle pas mal j'ai bien
sûr j'ai le respect de votre âge j'ai le
respect de tout ce que vous avez pu me
donner mais là franchement en 2005 vous
avez abattu
à wissous garder toute ma vie
ensuite
chose avec opportune en est ce qu'on a
travaillé six ensemble parce que j'ai eu
un petit la 6ème dauphine de mission et
à la travaillent ensemble
j'ai dit que vous avez été vraiment
rayons du soleil oui alors à près de
2500 en
1982 1990 je vais vous envoyer des sms
quand votre mari depuis son opération ça
c'était beaucoup plus tard c'était pas
en 2005 c'était beaucoup plus tard c'est
vrai vous m'avez envoyé un message pour
demander si jean-pierre allait bien et
comme la saf et où ils ne savaient
exploser les journalistes n'arrêtait pas
de ma paie et je vous ai dit oui merci
il va bien et vous m'avez juste répondu
c'est tout
vous allez continuer là on va peut-être
et j'ai donné j'ai transmis le témoin a
répondu sera à portée de tous et des
résultats
vous avez même dire abandonner ses pages
et j'ai quelquefois la tête qui
travaillent en france je pense que vous
aviez dit mais j'ai tant j'ai transmis
exactement les réponses mais les deux
oui et si on passait par un bisou en
tous les cas et les cars
ou ce que vous avez dit qu'on peut
traiter de noms mais non mais c'est
normal c'est vous qui m'avez qui
commence à me mal mal me parlez donc ça
m'a fait mal au coeur j'ai pas voilà on
va pas faire ping ont incité a eu plein
de choses donc mais tout ça c'est pas
grave vous savez la santé c'est ce qui
est le plus important dans la vie et que
l'on puisse se regarder dans un miroir
comme vous j'espère et il faut il faut
s'aimer dans la vie il faut arrêter de
chercher des embrouilles vous avez grâce
à vous il ya eu miss france qui a existé
ça a été une très très belle aventure il
faut laisser meighan les mains entre
sylvie tellier endemol qu il le fait
très bien il faut arrêter de vol
sabato jean-charles ans et
j'ai
bon
d'accord
avec
geneviève pardonnez-moi geneviève jeu
je t'embrasse très fort en tentant plus
là vraiment
[Applaudissements]
je te rappellerai à tunnel je te
rappellerai
mais oui vous allez vous réconcilier
goethe en france ma bonne vieille bisous
j'arrive pas la coupe bisous bisous
[Applaudissements]
hummer justement gardé de sylvie tellier
je crois que vous êtes venus avec des
révélations à ses excuses oui mais par
contre avant je voudrais dire quand même
deux mots c'est bien la preuve de bohain
window moi c'est fini c'est bien la
preuve qu'il n'y avait pas de trucage en
élection de miss france puisque madame
de fontenay ça y est ça on a compris au
prix à ces faits et vous me parlez de
l'avant tant des mois de juin quand même
y revenir c'est pas parce que madame de
fontenay juridiquement n'a plus le droit
et n'a plus les clés de miss france
qu'elle n'a plus droit de s'exprimer sur
le sujet oui mais elle ne le fait qu en
mal à ne le fait que en mal que en mâles
normales cormailles m non à l'arrivée on
est allé dans des bols tout y est
reparti comme en 40 quand on a quand on
a quand amandine petit miss france 2000
20 ans était nu et que tf1 lui a rendu
hommage un très bel hommage voilà il
faut aussi reconnaître les choses elle
l'a dit dans un communiqué mal donc elle
ne dit pas tout ce qui va pas mais elle
vit aussi ce qui va et c'est très
important que les téléspectateurs est en
croissance geneviève de fontenay dans un
concours miss france elle avait 22 ans
elle orne aujourd'hui la médecine
fait fort boyard
épouvantable pour boyer enfants moyart
vulgaire l'épouvantable parce que les
mains des équations pierre pour son
franc parler voilà la télé vous quand
vous y tient
[Applaudissements]
vulgaire gens venaient de nathalie dahon
s'abonner mes sentiments
sont nathalie nathalie je voudrais
donner un conseil à rémy qui doit y
avoir merdé là
[Rires]
j'avais dit non et encore merci non non
pas toi monsieur hubert
desbiens poliquin secondes vous deviez
faire des révélations exclusives c'est
aussi métayer ça nous intéresse oui
alors justement dans le cadre de l'
ouvrage que je prépare de clean
vingtaine d'années il ya un faisceau
d'indicés précis et concordants qui
circulent au sujet de la taille de ces
8es lille vous en avez vous même parlé
dans l'émission élément est
effectivement de requins s'est refermé
info
[Rires]
4 de cet ouvrage oui tout à fait vous
pouvez la diffuser j'ai une sommation
interpellative d'huissier que j'ai donné
à voir aux rédactions voilà qui demande
en 2002 à sylvie tellier de se faire toi
faisait
pour faire ils ces satanés fils ont été
faits par mademoiselle aurélie brin
aurélie brun c'est une miss loire forez
qui a été élu mister x qui n'avaient pas
la taille qui a été émis des temps
destitué et elle a demandé à s'éviter
les d'aller faire toi des séries télé ne
s'est jamais rendu se fasse assez joli
encore et là c'est encore truqué
l'élection de sylvie tellier n'aurait
pas dû à marsan c'est ça qu'on lui dira
donc pas seul sur un véhicule qu'est ce
qu'on en a à [ __ ] quelle famille 72
alors est ce qu'il est c'est un fait ce
qu'il dit c'est que l'élection c'est le
monde s'est emporté le réseau y compris
l'intérêt général du concours miss on
sent bien que l'excusé jeune fille qui
elle a fait ses preuves à les
formidables avec les miss france
il est vrai qu'on exclut des vhu travail
j'ai pensé vous il m'a lancé à longueur
de fruits
l'isle
adam de fonds pec latina ancien de 10
ans
l'érection des noms comme djibo laïty
bonne amie c'était deux yade n'y a pour
but de mettre les partis au front à
l'est par
sa tante et les enfants après hubert
hubert vous dis très clairement que
l'élection de miss sylvie tellier nez
est truqué l'élection de miss elle
n'aurait pas dû y assister mais valide
mais non juguler l'aurait dû se
soumettre tu ne me faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai pas dit jeudi certain moment
et comme l'a dit monsieur vers des
villes comme ça c'est contador qui pose
question sur la taille de sine qua non
c'est quand même la nuit ce présentateur
première elle n'est pas responsable de
ça c'est la faute du comité qu il la
recrute donc c'est truqué alors n'ayez
pas fermée mais alors c'est truqué à
nantes en 2001 on s'en fou maintenant
vivre aisément c'est important avant que
la directrice générale de l'organisation
côté respecter c'est madame de ce qu'il
est allé les buts et madame de fargo que
vous êtes en train dé encore de saper
sur madame de fonds
ont travaillé pour qui roule
accor et la cure au fond c'est
quand même raison sur le fait que subit
tellier qui passe son temps à casser
certaines listes ils ont fait des photos
qui était inquiète ses détenteurs monde
son élection il ya quand même un
problème quelque part il a fait de
critiquer certaines miss qui se dénude
eux c'est le principe même tennis
couverts s'entendait bien d'accord les
polémiques ont toujours une place du
concours miss france et justement ça
fonctionne pourquoi parce que ça le
concours qui rassemble cinq concours il
parle des gens parce qu'on peut
s'identifier à la miss auvergne qui est
dans une polémique on peut identifier
notre cousine soeur notre ami et c'est
donc ça c'est ça c'est quelque chose de
très important et c'est la raison pour
laquelle les polémiques fonctionne et
sur les anciennes miss et des attaques
de madame de fontenay est aujourd'hui
miss france c'est un cdi avis pourquoi
parce qu'après le jazzman qu'elle
maîtrise aux télévisions elle se
transforme au marie ange nardi sur
instagram pour faire du thé là ça me
dérange dans dit non ça me dérange pas
du tout cela concerne une évolution du
concours tandis qu'à votre époque n'a
tellement il me débrouiller voilà vous
avez eu débrouillez bien venir devraient
pas d'excès aussi facile aux médias et
ça c'est une évolution fondamentale
est-ce que c'est vrai que vous croulez
sous les mises en demeure endemol ne pas
faire le bouquin de vos terres et cetera
oui j'ai eu plusieurs mises en demeure
de la part dont des mollahs ce sujet
mais
c'est une question dont le font en fait
ils vous reprochent de dire n'importe
quoi
il me reproche de faire une enquête
extrêmement sérieuse et ils ont peur que
des éléments sortent dans ce match est
le fait d'essayer de faire taire ce
n'est pas d'hier c'est une question
est-ce que rage dans votre livre
l'interview est ce que vous balancer ça
aussi je m'allonge quoi bein sylvie
tellier n'aurait pas dû les attentes et
parce qu'elle était mais pas la
révélation il ya qu'est ce que oui il y
aura des révélations mais la révélation
ne seront pas trash ce sont des
révélations parce que ce sont des
éléments que les gens ne connaissent pas
que les français méconnaissent à sa
tasse et s'il votera les arbitres le
bordel dans les coulisses clairement
non mais attendez laissez moi parler
on va créer des polémiques vous pendant
qu obama parlerait de racisme nous livre
le crois oui oui eu du racisme à miss
france y
aura bien encore et toujours à miss
france on les a mis là je crois que
c'est intéressant je remercie m et a eu
le dernier mot ces derniers mois et nés
dont l'une serait d'avoir
une analyse historique et sociologique
qui n'a pas pour objectif de faire
polémique mais miss france fait
polémique parce que c'est un concours
qui passionne c'est vrai